today we're going to be covering blend
modes in webgl
and 3js understanding how and why they
work
and as an added bonus i'm going to show
you a much more advanced way to do
blending
so since we're covering blend modes we
won't be doing as much code as normal
now if you already know everything there
is to know about this topic
feel free to skip ahead to whatever time
it is i fill in here
if you just came here for the additive
alpha explanation
first off i've got a little simple
project setup going here
as you can see there's not much to it
mostly just the same basic setup we used
to create a 3d basic world tutorial
this is intentionally pretty simple over
here i've got some quads that i'm going
to render onto the screen
and these lines here change the blend
mode so that we can see the effects of
different blend modes
running it just shows a quad along with
some info on the side
the whole point of this thing is that
we'll be able to observe how changes to
the blend mode affect the overall image
here i'll go flip the blend mode so if i
change this line here to additive and
re-rerun this
you can see that the images change and
we've got this one that's blending over
top the
other using this additive blend mode
and we can swap this for other blend
modes and the result shows up in the
project
let's take a step back now and
understand what exactly is going on here
how webgl
and 3gs blend one image onto another how
that's controlled essentially
let's start with some terminology you've
got the destination
or as it's often shortened to dst
which is what's already on the screen in
essence
then you've got the source or src and
that's the image you're compositing onto
the destination
and all this is controlled by a couple
functions that you can use to change
how things are blended onto the screen
how the source
and the destination are blended together
the first up is the blend function now
in webgl this is called gl.blendfunc
in 3gs you would supply values for the
blend source and blend dust
parameters on a material and these in
essence supply multipliers for the
source and destination colors
respectively
and there's a bunch of constants here
that can be supplied you can look over
the list here
let's step through a quick example let's
say that you supply the multipliers uh
one and zero so that means that for
every pixel on the screen
the final color is equal to the source
times one
plus the destination times zero which of
course
is just the source
if i change the values here on this line
and we run it you can see that the image
completely overwrites the background
let's try some other multipliers so
let's go with one
one so in this case that means the color
for every pixel on the screen
is a straight up addition of the old
color plus the new color
so the final color is equal to source
times one
plus destination times one let's go and
change this to 1
1 in the code and now that we run it you
can see that our image gets blended over
top
making the background brighter and one
thing to note here is that remember that
the edges of the image were black
and black is basically zeros so when you
add zero to the background color
nothing happens so this only brightens
up in the middle
now the second part of what controls
blending is the blend equation
and up until now our examples have
always added the first
and second parts together i.e it's
always been source
times source factor plus destination
times a destination factor
webgl and thus 3gs also define ways to
modify the equation itself
in webgl this is gl.blend equation and
in 3gs these are the predefined blending
equations
what this allows you to do is change how
source and destination are combined
so instead of addition if we want to
change this to subtraction
the previous example changes as well so
let's step through we'll use one one
again as our blending factors
but we use subtraction as our blending
equation
the final color for every pixel on the
screen would thus become source
times one minus destination times one
we can go into the code and change this
to subtraction and when we run it it
looks a lot different than the additive
version
notice the color changes as you go
towards the center where previously it
got lighter
it might seem that there's a like a
million options here
and there are but a lot of effects
mostly boil down to two modes
additive and alpha blending additive
blending is that glowy fiery look
that you get and we actually already
covered it it's the
source times one plus destination times
one example that we ran through earlier
and alpha blending isn't conceptually
that hard either
its source time source alpha plus
destination times
one minus source alpha which you may
notice is just a straight up linear
interpolation between the two colors
based on the alpha value
now if i use a texture with alpha and
change the code here to use alpha
blending
you get something that's composited over
top of the background
instead of brightening it up now let's
talk about why having a separate
additive and alpha kind of sucks
this is a neat trick that i actually
discovered when i was working on an xbox
360 slash
playstation 3 title back when i first
started working
first off let's look at the problem it's
solving let's say that i have a raging
fire going on
now fire also should have a bunch of
black smoke and ash coming out so let's
add some smoke coming out the top
if you have separate additive and alpha
blending modes then this has to be done
as two separate particle systems
meaning as we move the camera around one
of them has to draw in front of the
other either the smoke gets drawn first
or the fire does
or they might even pop from front to
back depending on the camera angle
either way it's not going to look great
contrast that too if i combine this all
into a single blend mode which means
that it's all a single particle system
look at what happens as i move the
camera around it's all seamless
way better looking to understand how
it's done we need to go back to the
blend factors for both additive and
alpha blending
so additive blending looks like this 1 1
or it can also be source alpha 1 where
you just want to have an option to
control the overall
fade with something other than just the
color and
alpha blending looks like source alpha
and one minus source alpha
so an additive the final color is equal
to source times source alpha
plus destination times one and in alpha
blending the final color is equal to
source times source alpha
plus destination times one minus source
alpha
and we need these to be the same
equation somehow
you can do it like this our new additive
alpha combination equation is going to
be source times 1
plus destination times 1 minus source
alpha
and we're going to have to write
ourselves a special shader
so this shader it needs to do two things
it needs to do the alpha blending itself
so here in the fragment shader we
multiply the final color by the alpha
by doing that the blend mode we
specified works exactly the same as
alpha blending
see source times 1 plus destination
times 1 minus source alpha since we're
manually multiplying the final color by
source alpha ourselves
this is exactly the same as alpha
blending
watch i'll change the blend mode here in
our example program and this works just
like alpha blending
next for this to do additive blending we
need the one minus source alpha part
to be equal to one that's easy
we need the source alpha to be zero so
that means that one minus zero is equal
to one
and we can do that by having a special
blend mode value in the shader that gets
passed down per particle
and we simply multiply the alpha value
by that
so if the blend value is one the shader
outputs a normal alpha value
and if the blend value is zero the alpha
value turns into zero
and this whole thing becomes additive
and that's it
once you do those two small tweaks you
have a combined blend mode that does
both
and your particle system takes a giant
leap forward in both simplicity
and in looks hope you enjoyed this
make sure to like and subscribe as
always leave a comment and especially
let me know if there's a subject you
want covered and i'll add it to my to-do
list
source code is up on github blah blah
blah do whatever you want with it just
don't ask me to support it
i'll see you next time cheers